I am venture shall the director of the
Colombia Peru surveillance program and
on behalf of the Alliance Program in the
School of International and public
affairs it's a great pleasure for me to
welcome you all at Columbia for a unique
discussion on the non-proliferation
issue and iron obviously our discussion
tonight is extremely timely as the
reduction of nuclear weapon production
has mobilized in two short relation
affairs in the past month as the debate
hovers over Iran as today celebrated the
anniversary of the Iranian Revolution
and while France is currently presiding
to the Security Council of the United
Nations we are extremely fortunate to
have with us tonight the French
ambassador to the United Nations with
Jojo haha ho who can accepted our
invitation tonight to engage in a debate
with the students and the faculty of
Columbia University obviously our topic
tonight is a widely taught across
schools and across departments at
Columbia you never see enough great
interest to many of our students and our
faculty and I like to take some time to
thank a few of my colleagues at Columbia
who promoted this event with us in
particular I'd like to thank the United
Nations Studies program at ciba and Miss
Elizabeth and Amalia the Middle East
Institute at Columbia University the CDT
are the center of the study of democracy
generation and religion the IRC PL the
Institute for religion culture and
public life and the Department of French
studies at Columbia University and now
on behalf of all of them in the contact
community is a great pleasure for me to
welcome to Colombia ambassador jajaja
home who is the permanent representative
of friends to the United Nations in New
York a former ambassador of friends to
Israel from 2003-2006 jajaja Idaho is
so a former deputy secretary-general for
the French Ministry of Foreign Affairs a
foreign and European adversary and the
direct a former director-general for
political efforts and security and in
that capacity Jehovah the principal
negotiator of the three sanction
resolutions that were taken by the UN
Security Council on Iran on behalf of
between 2006 and 2008 so thank you very
much John Bassett Oliver Frey accepting
our invitation tonight thank you in
particular I have to say on behalf of
two of your alma maters that is to say
the a coping technique ET on support who
are as you know two pillars of the
Alliance Program we also very fortunate
to have with us tonight professor
Mitchell yet will be our moderator
tonight Richard Elliot is a professor of
history at Columbia University and a
highly respected member and former
director of the Middle East Institute at
Columbia professor bill yet specializes
in Middle East history and the social
and institutional history of Islamic
countries he is the author among many
others of the camel in the will and the
case for the Christian is the mix
civilization published in 2006 so will
now open the floor to ambassador arrow
for his remark that will be followed by
a discussion misc professor bill yet and
then we will open the floor to the Q&A
which is a great much valued tradition
at Columbia University for those of you
who are not familiar to our gatherings
please be prepared to be requested to
stand in line behind the mic to ask your
questions thank you again for both of
you for being with us tonight for a
unique discussion your presence with us
certainly embodies what we are the
Orions program try to do a semester
after semester both in Paris and in New
York that is to say attempt to offer
platform for debate a platform
transatlantic dialogue on the pressing
issues on
x always rooted in the accademia thank
you again good evening I actually I I
nearly canceled my this this this
meeting because the issue is so
sensitive that I really am a bit
terrified but what I'm going to say so
I'm going first to tell you and not here
to discuss the news so I'm not going to
answer any questions about the news you
know really i'm here i'm not going to
discuss about you know the the most
recent or the near future developments
in the in the Iranian nuclear crisis you
know this issue is too sensitive it's
negotiated by a few individuals and it's
not possible to discuss it in public in
real time it doesn't mean that I'm not
going that i'm going to say nothing it
really means and neither i try not to be
a typical diplomat you know really
typical diplomat would say nothing
during two hours so what I'm going to
say maybe will be maybe less exciting
especially for for for the journal is to
be but I hope that I at least I try to
help you to understand the crisis so my
my my approach will be analytical and
and based on the facts and on my own
experience you know I've been the French
negotiator since 2006 and 2 2009 and
actually before I had worked on these
issues for five or six years I let you
draw your own opinion from this analysis
so the analysis would be mine the
opinion will be will be yours so I make
a few points to open the discussions a
few points and to try to make understand
a very long long story the very the
first point is that it's a very long
story it started in 2002 when actually
we were suddenly informed by several
sources that there was a clandestine
nuclear Iranian program and that which
was actually quite a quite extensive in
2003 the free European ministers of
Foreign Affairs from from France from
Germany and United Kingdom send a letter
to to Iran and after that they went to
to Tehran to try to say we have to
discuss it we have to negotiate to
negotiate with you so it had started in
2003 with the free Europeans and later
on three other countries have joined the
group of negotiators which means China
Russia and the United States so we have
created what is called the e3 plus three
group the issue free the free Europeans
plus free China Russia and in the United
States so we have the international
community has been negotiating with Iran
since 2003 so six years so it's a very
very long story so first i think i want
to emphasize a few points first I think
the nature of the Iranian nuclear
program is raising concerns in the
international community at large let's
be you know the International Agency of
atomic energy has voted to resolutions
on it the UN Security Council has voted
five resolutions among these five
resolutions free of them have imposed
sanctions against Iran and these five
resolutions have been voted with no
dissent with no dissent Libya has voted
sanctions against Iran South Africa as
voted sanctions against Iran you know in
other words to be blunt it's not Iraq
revisited you know it's not the West do
nor against Iran it's the international
community at large which
expressing its concerns as you know
France Germany China Russia have opposed
the war against Iran Iraq against Iraq
in 2003 and now not only not only they
consider that really there is a problem
but actually they are in the driver's
seat of you know of their members of
this group of six countries we tried to
find a diplomatic outcome to the crisis
so that's the first point you know it's
not to know the West it's really the
international community which expresses
its concerns about this program the
second point is nobody denies the right
of Iran to nuclear civilian energy
nobody you know that's not the problem
the right which is enshrined in the
non-proliferation treaty has been
reaffirmed by all the decorations of the
six ministers it has been reaffirmed by
all the resolutions of the UN Security
Council the demand of the international
community is is simple what we are
asking to the Iranians is the
restoration of the international
confidence in the civilian nature of the
Iranian nuclear program the restoration
of the international confidence in the
civilian nature of the Iranian nuclear
program the question is to define with
Iran the measures which could be taken
which while respecting the rights of
course of Iran would reassure the world
it's what we have tried for six years we
have tried to open a negotiation with
Iran to have to define together these
these measures Third Point as I've said
it's a very long story 2003 and I can
tell you that since 2003 we have tried
everything to open a negotiation we
really want to reach a diplomatic
solution to the crisis so the free
Europeans in the first time and later on
the D 3 plus 3
we have met the Iranians dozens of times
hundreds of hours to try to open the
negotiation we have made a lot a lot of
different proposals proposals on the
procedure proposal on the substance we
are presented to Iran in 2006 and 2008
to proposal and compassing a wide range
of fields of cooperation where we have
not discussed only nuclear we have
really proposed to the Iranians a wide
range of cooperations in fields going
from agriculture to civilian to civilian
aviation actually we went and I was
member of the group we went to Tehran in
June 2008 to present the second the
second proposal and lastly and not the
least of course the Obama administration
has offered to open the dialogue without
preconditions with Iran in a bilateral
on the bilateral basis as you can guess
we the six countries we have maintained
an intensive dialogue with the Iranians
at all level and all on all issues
President Putin went to Tehran i think
it was in 2007 or 2008 october the
minute the Chinese Ministry of Foreign
Affairs the Russian Foreign Minister
Foreign Affairs they went to Tehran to
no avail and and that's the problem that
that you that we are facing and that we
are really faced still facing today we
have not succeeded and let's be frank we
have not succeeded to open a negotiation
it's not a question of saying that our
offer was not a sufficient it's simply
that the negotiation has never started
in six years that we have never had even
the beginning of negotiation on the
substance of our proposal they have been
dismissed they have not been discussed
we have never been told or what you are
is not enough because it would not be in
the beginning no simply we have not
succeeded to open a negotiation on the
on the Iranian side we have never had
concrete proposals we have we have heard
public announcements and still recently
but these public announcements have been
either not followed by any concrete
proposal or actually had been denied
discreetly afterwards so again we have
not succeeded to enter into a
negotiation on our terms or in their
terms and I really want to repeat 44
because what what should be obvious to
to all of us our our only goal is to
open a negotiation and to reach an
agreement this crisis is too serious and
I'll come to to it I'll come to it point
five hour our approach since the
beginning has been called the dual-track
approach on one track you try to open
the negotiation and on the other track
if you don't succeed to open a
negotiation to put you put a pressure on
the other side and it is the sanctions
as i have said three resolutions of
sanctions have been voted by the
Security Council into from 2006 to 2008
the sanctions are not an end in
themselves their goal is to convince
Iran to enter into a genuine negotiation
on measures are repeat myself to restore
confidence in the civilian nature of
their program nothing more nothing else
nothing less and when I said nothing
more of course I really it the message
behind it is we are not in the regime
change game we are here we are ending
the civilian the nuclear issue there is
no hidden agenda but the wheel to
respond adequately to the concerns of
the international community 66 a failure
not a failure
to reach a diplomatic solution that we
have been striving for will be extremely
serious extremely serious first the
future of the non-proliferation treaty
npt and Beyond of the non-proliferation
system is at stake because the military
nuclearization of of your arm or as a
reality or even as a potential threat
you know really even as a potential
threat we lead other neighboring
countries to consider that their
security depends on their following the
same path you know we I think there are
two main proliferation crisis when I was
a student in the 70s I was taught in two
thousand there will be 15 nuclear powers
15 and I was the least Argentina Brazil
South Africa and actually we have
succeeded to keep large early the genius
in the bottle and today there are two
nuclear crisis North Korea and Anira
North Korea the crisis is managed by by
the neighbor by the neighbors the
six-party towards you know followed by
Russia China South Korea Japan you know
these countries are trying to solve the
problem for negotiation but what is
striking is that even if North Korea
actually as easily clear power it
doesn't mean that note that South Korea
Japan have declared the day afterwards
okay since they have the bomb we are
going to at the bottom so that in a
sense the crisis is delimited in the
Middle East it's quite different in the
Middle East nobody could say what will
be the incentive for for the neighbors
for the neighbors considering that there
they can consider that their security is
at stake that the region is very fragile
and very very unstable and of course
beyond the region once the genius is out
of the bottle other countries will feel
obliged for security or status reasons
to follow each will be the end
the non-proliferation treaty second
point of course and that i should say
very easy the Middle East is a fragile
region the inflammatory decorations that
we have heard in Tehran have of course
raised genuine concerns some even fears
elsewhere a military confrontation
couldn't be excluded would the
diplomatic effort fail we do want to
avoid this disaster it's it's very easy
to imagine what could be the
consequences in this region of a
military confrontation so I'm going to
to conclude to conclude here I've tried
to give you in a sense the logic of our
of our common effort you know we have
been working together the free Europeans
China Russia and the US and I think it's
a remarkable our basketball factor of
course there are nuances between the six
countries about there are nuances there
are also nuances between the free
Europeans there are nuances between
Europeans and the Americans between the
and so on you know because we have
different interests different geography
it's totally normal I think what is
uniting us and and that's the
fundamental what is uniting us is the
conviction that year we have a concern
and here we have to address it and and I
guess that I'm sure actually this
concern this common concern is still
there and the commonweal of the six
countries is is to work its work
together after all on the substance of
the sanctions on the timing of the
sanctions since 2006 actually since 2003
we have had discussions we have had
these agreements we have a dissertation
doubts but I can testify because I've
negotiated three resolutions of
sanctions that at the end of the day
after long hours and nights and grueling
process of reconciliation between the
different different conceptions I think
we have always
the six countries which means the p5 the
five permanent members plus Germany it's
another way of presenting the six the p5
plus Germany we have always reached an
agreement and and an agreement because
we all share the same concern and as
I've said other countries run this group
are really sharing the concern and want
like us that we reach a diplomatic
diplomatic solution to a very serious
crisis thank you thank you very much mr.
ambassador a very diplomatic
presentation as we would have expected
so I want to spend a few minutes
pressing you perhaps a little a little
different fashion and I'll try and make
this brief enough that starting in about
15 minutes we will have a general
question and answer session in remarks
that you made on January 28 which I
think was three days before you took up
your chairmanship of Security Council
you made some interesting points one of
them was that in order to think of
deterrence as a model for the future of
Iranian nuclear relations one had to
assume that of the parties that are in
potential conflict are reasonable
parties and you observed that the
comments of mr. Ahmadinejad did not fit
that definition of reasonable and yet I
recall vividly as a teenager Nikita
Khrushchev saying we will bury you and
Americans taking that
as a literal threat of nuclear
annihilation in the way that some people
in Israel and some friends of israel
take president Ahmadinejad's comments
about Israel as being literally
promising or threatening a nuclear
annihilation seven years later
Khrushchev back down from that in 1963
but for years that phrase we will bury
you was brought up again and again and
again to show the unreasonableness at
the other side and yet deterrence
succeeded during that period and then at
another point in the same session you
remarked when you were talking about the
threat of a nuclear Iran to the Arab
countries you said that in fact Iran may
be more of a threat to the Arab
countries of the Gulf than to Israel and
so it raises the question in my mind as
to how you evaluate the Israeli
understanding of Iran's program as
constituting an existential threat to
Israel or differently put whether you
feel that Iran's the Iranian nuclear
program that reached a weapon or
threshold stage is more a regional
threat than a particular threat to one
particular country thank you I think
it's it's a good heavy does that to
diplomats should never make decoration
to
actually it's no the question of data
rhymes the first you don't answer to the
of course to the question again if
military nuclearization of your arm or
even as I said reality or the potential
threat as I've said first each will eat
food it will lead a lot of countries to
follow the path in any case in the case
of Israel decay there is a question mark
of well why not to have a deterrence
which means to go by that the NPT is
dead which is already a victim that
deserves some consideration after that
you have the case of Israel you could
consider that why not a deterrence
simply a balance of deterrence between a
nuclear design we can suppose that it's
a nuclear power and a Iran if Iran
becomes a nuclear nuclear power the
prime of deterrence again and is based
on the assumption by the leadership of
the two sites that the other side is
following the same logic the same
rationality and again here of course I'm
not in the in the brain and of of the
asylum leaders simply I know Israel and
I know the story of the Jewish people
and when somebody says that it will
believe that these countries should be
to disappear from the map from the map
if you don't say that you want to
destroy say that you think that is I
should disappear from the map I think it
it's feeling so it's fitting some gut
feeling among the among the asylums so I
simply said that the question ears
on these bases will the Israelis accept
the logic of deterrence with with this
leadership and I think it's a big I
guess it's a big question mark I don't
have the answer but i think it's a it's
a big question mark you know really it's
a because what you were referring to the
public discourse the prime is also the
nuclear deterrence and it's very
difficult to understand but it's really
managed by him sense by by the
leadership and it's a sort of eye to eye
face to face reality between the Soviet
and the Americans it was the case and in
a sense never the other side as as
believed that aside as believe that the
other side was was going to whisk the
total destruction of its own country so
will it be possible to have the same
balance between between Israel and Iran
I don't have the answer by definition
really simply I again I I've lived in
instyle six years of my life I my doubt
that the Israelis we take the risk but
that's that's an open question that I
think that's opinion that everybody can
have is own opinion a country which
which the second question a country
which has a nuclear deterrent in a sense
nuclear deterrence being either you have
the bomb or or you are close to the
threshold of the bomb or you are
suspected to have the bomb in a sense
feels protected you know really feels
protected and it leads to a real
imbalance in the security in the
security in the part of the world you
know really you have a country suddenly
in in in the Gulf countries where
already you have a powerful country of
70 millions of inhabitants in front of
Earth countries which are less populous
there is already a sort of
question which is there about the
security you know and when introducing
the nuclear deterrence factor it
increases this this ? especially because
you can deterrence is also deterrents
nuclear deterrence is also active
against conventional it's a way of
balancing the conventional superiority
of your adversary so it means that with
nuclear deterrence the country can deter
from instance the US you know they can
share the u.s. from intervening in
conventional conventional terms because
the risk would be will be so so so be I
I was we were discussing it in this in
the stairs I give the example of of
India Pakistan in a really Pakistan
innocence was already always deter by
the convention of superiority of India
you know because India was obviously
superior in conventional terms while
becoming a nuclear power you know it has
a factor of establishing a military
strategy balance between the two
countries so again it's a veteran sister
logic which is apparently logic you can
consider it's also a bit crazy the
problem is that is something very
fragile which is based on assumptions on
both sides and the question is that
these assumptions are the result of
years and years of discussions of face
to face and the question and I don't
have the answer again is will it be
possible to have this logic of
deterrence in the in the Middle East a
region which is so unstable and so
fragile we don't want to run the risk
simply we don't want to run do is we
don't want to have not only the NPT
there
also the sort of that on the stability
of the Middle East that's a reason why
we want a diplomatic solution my second
question of starts from the observation
that the nuclear issue with Iran is
probably the most serious crisis that
the United States has experienced with
Iran since the hostage crisis in so far
as presidents have become personally
involved and expectations have been
raised and so forth and so on in the
hostage crisis there were severe
sanctions Iran was suffering eventually
suffering from war but before the war
broke out you had severe sanctions and
it was not clear why the hostages were
not we're not released why there was no
negotiation some people observed that
during the period the hostages were held
Iran had a referendum to approve a
constitution it elected a president an
elected to Parliament and then about one
week after the part of the one was
elected it got in touch with the US and
said now it's time to to deal the
hostage crisis in other words the
internal politics of the country seemed
to take priority over the over the
foreign policy you know stalemate the
question is whether the nuclear issue in
Iran is one that any Iranian can resolve
or whether there are internal issues in
Iran that make it difficult if not
impossible for a single Iranian figure
to make the tough decision and go public
with terminating the program and if that
is possibly the case
how does one appraise the internal
situation in Iran with respect to the to
the challenge of your security council
is facing up again we don't want to to
to terminate the Iranian nuclear program
you simply want to define measures for
monitoring this is for ram we are not in
the game of domestic politics in Iran we
are not in the game of domestic politics
we are first I think because we are
diplomats and foreign we are in foreign
relations we are coping our relationship
with is with the government of the
Islamic Republic of Iran there there is
a political activities in Iran we are we
are following it of course but we really
we are not we are not playing on this
game playing these games our conviction
is that this nuclear program has existed
for 20 years so in a sense it has been
endorsed by a lot of different members
of the union leadership so we could
consider that it's not a question of one
wing or another wing you know really
it's it has to be a decision of Iran you
know to consider that you know every
policy is based on profit and and and
cost that's the really the prophet of of
a negotiation is is more important that
the cost of the confrontation with the
International International commune
okay thank you very much my third and
final question arises from the comments
you made in your opening statement where
you said and I think this is a correct
quotation that the the goal of the
Security Council or of the the the six
is quote the restoration of
international competence in the civilian
nature of the nuclear program the word
restoration prompts the question as to
whether the origin of the Iranian
nuclear program was civilian in nature
and if then either acquired a military
aspect or it could acquire military
aspect after all the Shah of Iran
himself had called for a civilian
nuclear program of a very substantial
scale before the Revolution so when you
say restoring international confidence
how would that be done what sort of
thing could the Iranians publicly commit
to that would in your view be convincing
to the international community that
civilian that the civilian nature of the
program has been restored no first
restoration because Iran has had nuclear
act nuclear activities for a long time
and
there are pretty legitimate as I've said
beyond this program for for medical
reasons for instance of research or
research there was this discovery in
2002 of a clandestine program and so
that was a sort of a shock for all the
international community especially
because there is this question of
enrichment Iran is enriching uranium and
nobody knows what what is the use of
this enrich uranium since Iran doesn't
have nuclear power plant it's like if
you buy gas before buying a car it
doesn't make a lot of sense in in
financial and in technical terms as for
the measures which could be taken again
that would be the result of a
negotiation let's discuss with our
Iranian counterparts you know really and
let's open the negotiation I can't tell
I can say what would be the result of
the negotiation I guess that on one side
people will ask some very strong
measures on the other side there will be
reluctance and at the end of the day
there will be a compromise and we will
again as I've said we want to discuss we
want to discuss what could be these
measures of course their ideas floating
around in terms for instance the
Additional Protocol order because it's
very technical so there is the
Additional Protocol of the International
Agency of atomic energy you know which
has been suspended by the
iranian parliament so we would want to
as it restored and implement it you can
also discuss specific measures of
monitoring off of control you know there
is there is a I think place there is
room for 444 foreign compromise you know
the fact that the Russians and the
Chinese I think went to Tehran as you
can guess that we are ready to find a
compromise in the sense as I've said are
nuances among the six it's not it's not
a mystery and you can guess where we're
more less on the range of positions
where hard where are the six and
actually the Russians of the Chinese
again they didn't reach any result on
these only cos on this you know so
that's I guess good evidence that first
there is a sense of compromise on our
side secondly simply the negotiation has
not started thank you very much I'm now
going to open the floor to questions if
you have a question please go to the
microphone at the center of the room and
form a line I'm going to take three
questions and then allow the Ambassador
to respond and then three more and give
them a chance to respond so that we
don't you know get Machine get
constipated on this issue and I urge you
to make your questions clear and
succinct and refrain from from making
speechless all right yes sir your first
stomach Republic is not the same as was
year ago can you please introduce
yourself yeah I say stomach Republic
he's not the same as it was she would
like God would she like you to identify
yourself but I'm a new chef Emmalee why
I live in New York Islamic Republic is
not the same as what year ago it has
lost legitimacy and so internal politics
you said you are diplomat you are not
interested in internal pal to give Iran
but why not you are negotiating with
whom you're going to negotiate and the
ypres government is not legitimate so
what's the what it means for the
negotiation and secondly that the other
question my second question this is true
in relation to Pakistan if the Pakistan
deterrent was the patter was India but
if the government fails aren't you
worried about the Pakistan thank you by
the way when I said take three questions
my li what I meant was one question from
three different speakers that each
person being invited to to have multiple
questions but please yes Cory to help my
name is Miriam I just like to know you
said they don't want to start
negotiation neither your terms either
your their terms I like to know more
about these terms what is their term
that you that we said we want to start
negotiation but they don't want whatever
terms you didn't explain those terms
neither yours nor dares thank you thank
you
we actually have three questions at this
point so perhaps know what I was seeing
of course we are not we are not that
stupid and which means that we are
interested by analysis of the
International internal situation of your
on when you are negotiating I'm sure
that your engines are interested by
internal situation of the United States
for instance of course you know really
so we try to understand which works and
where where it will go and where we're
out the the the decision-making process
for f words you know really we have
tried what I've said is in a sense is a
year talking in official terms to send a
very very strong message that we are not
here I have said already for regime
change well not when I say it's not we
are not interested bye what is happening
but simply we are not going to play on
that you know it's a different it's a
different issue the question of the HTML
see that's your or your opinion there is
we are facing a government which is a
government of Islamic Republic of Iran
you know and that's the only counterpart
that we have and I don't see two two
wells we could talk Pakistan it's not
the topic of our discussion tonight so
the terms the terms when I've said on
our terms on their terms I would say if
their way of terms on their terms we
were really at least discussed their
terms they have never offered terms of a
negotiation the other Elliot's never
never you know really it's really
repeating that your Iran has inalienable
rights to to civilian nuclear energy and
about nobody can defy the run from its
energy of all rights and so on but
but basically nothing really nothing
else no answer to our proposal our terms
I think as I've said in 2006 and after
that we have refined and complete we
have refined and enlarge it in 2008 we
have the six ministers and the six
countries and the second time it was
actually signed by the six ministers
including Secretary Rice Condoleezza
Rice we were said to the Iranians if the
nuclear issue is solved we are offering
you you know full integration into the
international community and as you know
for the moment beyond the sanctions on
linked to this issue Iran is submitted
to some sanctions for instance US
sanctions as you know there are strong
US sanctions against Iraq so there was
an offer for instance the Orion
subproblems to buy spare parts for the
aircraft's because they are American oh
and they
they are not allowed to do it US
sanctions so what we were offering was
to say to the uranians we are ready to
cooperate with you on a lot of different
issues I said agricultural civilian you
know finance security we are ready to
take you as a legitimate normal member
of the international community and and
and there was under this framework his
contacts there was the nuclear issue we
were again provided actually provided
that we could reach an agreement on on
the declaration that was our Terms and
and again it was open terms because when
I have not answered to the question
about what measures we could ask the
uranians it was not only a diplomatic
way out it was simply because it has to
be the result of a negotiation you know
really that's that's the work of the
diplomats you know to reach a compromise
I can't forecast what will be the result
of a negotiation so so there was if we
had reach a compromise with the Iranians
there was beyond solving the problem
there was the the prospect of the
reintegration of Iran into the
international community it was our
political terms as for the detailed
terms as I have said they have never
asked us what where the detail the
detailed terms so we couldn't even as
I've said start start a negotiation
hi my name is Erica I'm a PhD student in
the political science department here
you've spoken a lot about how different
states in the region might react to an
Iranian and open Iranian nuclear weapons
program specifically that we might
expect to see proliferation so I'm just
curious what you think if that does
occur what the international community
could do about it practically given that
sanctions haven't really worked sorry so
like what you know practical diplomatic
moves are there if Iran does openly go
nuclear mr. ambassador could you speak
about some of the politics surrounding
um oil and gas especially with Russia
China and Iran first if again the first
question as I've said you know really I
diplomacy is not I think hard science
and it's it's not either reading in the
crystal ball and as I've said there is
first there is the risk of a military
confrontation you know really we don't
know whether countries will accept this
prospect really and it's useless to say
that it will be a major disaster in this
part of the world in any part of the
world but especially in this part of the
world secondly as i have said also the
risk is that simply the collapse of the
non-proliferation treaty and and you
know again in the 70s it was already a
risk now it would be much in a sense
it's mo it will be much more dangerous
because in a sense it's much easier now
to get a ball getting the bomb is not is
more is cheaper and easier that it was
in the 70s so each i think it will
really
really and tail at the end of our the
non-proliferation don't profession
tricky so what what to do why I don't
know what will we do I really don't know
you know I think very often the
diplomats are described as as as cynical
a diplomat is in charge of the national
interest of this country and the
national interest of the country
whatever is this country are many fold
and some of them are economic financial
and a legitimate you know really the
jobs of our in our in our work of our
you know in our factories there are a
legitimate interest so when you are
facing such an issue you have to take
into account all the interest and when
we were negotiating when when I was
negotiating the sanctions the resolution
of sanctions first I had to negotiate
with my Treasury because of course it
has consequences on on the French trade
the the EU trade with Iran has decreased
by thirty percent in 2008 I think or
seven so it has consequences well its
financial consequences and the different
countries are exposed to disc reskin
different manners you know because first
their trade is is is as different for
you know for instance one of European
countries as more medium and short size
cooperations so it means that if these
corporations are losing it a deal it's
much more painful than if it is a large
cooperation so it's it's obvious that
the first country will be may be more
sensitive more assitant it does not mean
that is cynical or injury but it always
really is it different it depends also
on your energy your energy dependence
you know some countries simply for
historical reasons or some reasons don't
import oil from your arm the US you know
really why other countries are 14.5
no one so of course the the one the some
countries are again more or less
sensitive so it's obvious that between
as I've said between the six countries
you have different interest which means
that you have also nuanced approach to
these new sanctions some country for
instance the sanctions are more more
actually targeting the train but it
means targeting the trade means the
state sponsorship of the trail you know
we we give you know with we don't
prevent trade but simply we say that we
what is prevented is for instance state
assurance for you know Willie's and
among the countries some of them are
more as the state as more importance
than other countries which means that
when you you prevent for instance
assurance reassurance of trade by estate
in some countries the steak is very
active all the countries the state is
not active so it has different
consequences so you know so it's very
complicated and and again I want to go
beyond the Orion example you are always
in my job you have always to face and
and part of my job is to understand the
other side to say if if such a search it
doesn't agree with me it's not because
it is bad and that good settlement area
but also maybe because it is his
interests are different so that's the
case obviously that's the case some
countries are more dependent on Iranian
oil than other countries which is not
the case of Russia which is not
dependent at all on
no but we've arshad there is also the
prime of the geographic proximity so you
know yet there is another element which
means which can lead to some difference
of approach differential approach the
United States they are very far there
are no financial economic relationship
whatsoever if you are not limited to
really very small interest so do the
Americans in the sense are much more
prone to strong sanctions because in a
sense strong sanctions actually cost to
the you across nothing to the US and as
a French modest was saying in the 17th
century you're always ready to accept
the sacrifice of your neighbor that's
also reality that are really that
reality and in considering also the
economy situation you know jobs are of
some interest are important I things
like that as the president of the French
Republic has repeatedly said my country
is in favor of of strong sanctions
mr. ambassador I'm oh so very academic
student here at CPAP doing a master's in
international fest I'd like to ask you a
very very simple question very very
naive perhaps but certainly the question
that any or the majority of citizens of
the Middle East would ask if when when
confronting this issue concerning the
the Iranian nuclear question and that is
the they would immediately think of the
the Western double standards relating to
to Israel possessing that the the the
bomb the nuclear capacity do you not
think that the the moral superiority of
the powers that are trying to negotiate
with Iran is it's lost because of fact
of not addressing that that issue first
certainly that's the position of the the
muck that your average middle eastern
citizen including me they read much with
many of their ends themselves I presume
thank you I'm surprised by this question
Thank You ambassador you're alluding to
China earlier and I was just wondering
are there any thoughts being developed
about a plan B in the event that china
is not able to be on board for these new
round of sanctions other other ideas
being developed or not but first on you
soil you know really I to prepare the
answer to the question because I knew
that sooner or later it will come first
I think if you ran as in conditions if
Iran has nuclear ambitions and we want
to be reassured about it I I insist on
this point these ambitions have nothing
to do with this I'll you know really
raising the raising Israel in this in
this factor in this crisis is a
political argument frankly which is used
like in other issues in the risk region
to hide the real issue I first the
Iranian nuclear program I started with
the shop at the time of the Shah you
know Iran was a close ally and and the
clothes in the close friend of Israel
after that it has been relaunched after
the war with Iraq in a 98 88 1988
because Iran has been targeted by
chemical weapons chemical weapons which
were sent by by Iraq so again yah yes
i'll add nothing to do nothing I you can
identify as the source of the the
Iranian nuclear program after that it's
very useful because you it has always a
big a big effect in the public opinion
two ways to wait but frankly it's more
it's a smoke screen you know really for
the Iranian program Iran is not engaged
into a nuclear program because of Israel
it has nothing to its good as we same
Frenchy to both Gail to use it but it's
a political party political argument but
to go further
first again as I've said I'm I'm
defending the interest of my country as
I've said one of the first interest I
identify is the maintenance of the npg
and on the non-proliferation regime and
so far again I'm not aware that that
Israel which has not signed the entity
as violated its obligation or in any way
contributed to proliferation you know
really i don't see but maybe I'm right
but I have not have not seen and the
fact that your heart that Israelis may
be a nuclear power so far as not led to
undermining the the NPT while I do think
that in Iran which had signed the NPT if
you ran was violating the mpg it will be
an important and negative element I
think say that I'm not good I don't want
to dismiss your your question or your
your concern which i think you perfectly
right to say that it's it's a common
concern among in the men in the street
in the middle east and again i think it
goes beyond the the nuclear issue with
Anya nuclear issues it going also in
other issues and especially the hub the
israeli-palestinian conflict but having
say that we do support with the French
we do support wmv3 zone in the Middle
East a WMD free zone in the Middle East
and I think it has been accepted by most
of the countries or all the countries of
the region and we should we should work
on it and maybe the NPT review
conference would be could be a step into
this direction but WMD it's not only
nuclear it's WMD which means also
chemical weapons and biological weapons
and a lot of countries and not only
Israel actually a lot of countries in
the region have not signed the
convention on on chemical weapons and
and also the convention on biological
weapons and as you know deterrence is
nuclear nuclear but for some people
countries it's also nuclear versus
chemical or nuclear versus biological so
I think in a sense in first as a good
balanced in first first part i dismissed
your question in the second part I I I
joined you by saying that I think that
after we have solved this question I
think we should move forward to work on
the WMD 33 zone hello mr. um ambassador
my name is and Reyna Flores from Radio
friends international and you said in
your opening statement that the Security
Council had decided in the past to apply
sanctions to Iran but you said as well
and that if discussion is not working
then you have to make more pressure so
my question is what have been exactly
the sanctions to Iran the previous
sanction to Aaron and what would be the
sanctions this year I mean how are you
planning to increase the pressure if
that's the case and secondly if you
allow me on the first minister of
friends and Francois feel has declared
that your country would ask firmly to
apply sanctions to Iran and my question
is are you presenting this proposal to
the Security Council these days thank
you first I think there was a question
of China you know really and we are not
on the we are not yet or we are not
actually in in thinking of a plan B I
think it's crucial it's essential for
the legitimacy of what we are of which
we are doing it's totally essential to
work
chain even if it means waiting a bit
even if it means you know really we
really need needed China I think I
insist you know the legitimacy of what
we are trying i think is really largely
based on the fact that the p5 we are
united that china or shine we are and
and the free Western powers of the
Security Council we are we are united so
for its not only for the moment but I
think it's I wouldn't consider you know
really in a sense dunking or China you
know really I wouldn't consider as a
viable as a valuable solution on the
sanctions I you know they are public I'm
not going to make the least they are a
resolution 1737 1747 1803 reaffirmed by
resolution 1835 so you look at the the
UN the UN site and you have you had the
resolutions are about sanctions as I've
said I'm not going to discuss the news
so it means that my authorities are said
publicly that we want to have sanctions
significant sanctions but I'm not going
to discuss what what sort of sanctions
we are indeed proposing
thank you very much my name is Ali from
mission of Iran my name the nature of my
intervention rather than questioning
raising question is commenting on some
of the points that ambassador rice the
drink is introductory remarks and
actually an answer session in fact lots
of points raised by ambassador are
subject to denial discussion and counter
controversy but I don't want to get into
details I just want to answer to some of
the points that ambassador race in fact
the Ambassador you mischaracterize that
misrepresented some of the realities
underground and what happened what what
has happened since 2003 for example it
was stated that a negotiation did not
started really and that is not the case
I think and we and the three European
countries Iran and three European
countries negotiated for two years in
half why you want suspended its
enrichment activity which is it's right
under the NPT but at the end but at the
end because of the insistence of the
European part and that was originated by
the objection of the United States you
came up with a proposal that denied the
Iran's right to enrichment so we had
negotiations we were prepared to have
limited enrichment at that time but you
denied the right to enrichment and you
said that's the concrete objective if to
a non diversion and the second point
that you missed in presentation i think
is too
to refer to the reports of the IAEA the
reports of diarrhea are very clear that
in a setting that Iran has known as no
diversion to prohibited activities and
we are in full compliance with the NPT
so the concern is not the concern of
international community the concern is
the concern of some Western countries
which have the veto power in the
Security Council and the Security
Council is not representing the
international community that's why
international community is insisting on
reforming the Security Council and the
last point I don't want to dispute all
of the points that you raised I think we
should have keep in mind that Iran is
not seeking nuclear weapons but Iran
insists on its right to nuclear
technology and if we start with two
principles if we accept two principles
we can reach a final solution the first
principle is that Iran has the right to
nuclear technology and the second is
that Iran should not have nuclear
weapons I think that our counterpart are
negotiating counterparts in the 5+1
group should show seriousness about
addressing rather than rather than
dismissing enrichment right that the one
is entitled under the NPT with that
principles I think we can we can find
that we can find an exit to this issue
which we believe is solvable and
due to a dogmatic insistence by Western
countries we have not been able to to
result thank you very much thank thank
you first i think i'm not going to enter
in poly me it's not Western again since
as you know among the six there is
Russia and China and thats for sure in
China I've tried to reach a confirm
negotiate a compromise with Iran and
even succeed it's not Westar that's a
very point as for the reports of the
International Agency for atomic energy
here we disagree the International
Agency as repeatedly said that Iran is
not answering two questions about
alleged studies on military on military
military topics you know and the board
of governors of the International Agency
has voted to resolutions on on this
issue expressing its concerns i think
that the reports of the agency are
certainly online and you can you can
look at it you can look at it and you
can look at the last part i can even
advise you to go to the last paragraph
of the resolutions of the agency and i
saw the two principles we do agree with
these two principles but these two
principles were in the letter of the
three ministry of other ministers in
2003 and since then four five six years
six years we have not succeeded 22
to open the negotiation so I guess maybe
it's more complicated it's more
complicated but I think there is a wheel
of finding god forbid or finding a
diplomatic solution mr. ambassador this
week there was an article published in
the national interest by an American
political scientist who asserted that we
would not see a new round of sanctions
against Iran because certain members of
the Security Council namely Russia and
China had strategic interests in seeing
a nuclear Iran come to bear a nuclear
weapons holding Iran and those strategic
and dress are allegedly the fact that a
nuclear Iran would constrain US military
action in the Middle East can you
comment on this suggestion no it's not a
friendship I matter who can discuss
intellectuals realize we accept their
their imagination now the factories or
show in China as I've said our part of
active part of our goods they are voted
five resolution or 6 i'm always loss
meant now it's five resolutions against
you on three of them with with sanctions
so i guess there is no reason to doubt
or that they don't want to have it will
be 2 again to destabilizing you know
really it will be much too destabilizing
in the in the in the region and in the
world the end of the non-proliferation
you know as for the nuclear military
nuclear energy you can also argue that
you know they have don't want to to to
want to remain a ghost club so there are
five countries official nuclear powers
plus two out of the club and one and
other
so they don't want to had one country
more because it hurts a lot of
uncertainties to the to the strategic
balance in a sense you know Johannes
closer to Russia than it is to the US so
I really thought I really think it's a
bit far-fetched and it doesn't fit the
reality of the Chinese and Russian the
Russian diplomatic activities there is a
point that you I want to join our
Iranian friend is we want we do want the
reform of the Security Council I think
president sarkozy has repeatedly said
that we need to have a Security Council
which is representative of the new the
new reality security consider is the
reflection of 1945 if we want to keep
the effectiveness of the council we have
to enlarge it to the emerging powers so
with UK we have made several proposals
to try to move forward the process which
is a voting process because in the UN I
think everybody tries to prevent its
neighbor to join the Security Council
which makes a lot of a lot of square
holes but we do want to be formed if
you'll print me a second question on the
issue of reform at the UN what positive
lessons do you think we can draw from
the Iranian example that we can possibly
bring to bear this spring at the NPT
review or in reforming the IAEA in the
future to help prevent cases like this
no I i do think first the fact of having
worked with weave
you know the US Russia and China in a
sense is the positive element and it's
showing that we are going again with all
the nuances the different interests and
also some mistrust you know we we are
under the shadow of the Iraqi crisis you
know really so there is there was
especially especially last year or you
know some in some circles especially
Moscow the idea of saying well the
Americans are asking for for sanctions
but actually they want to use it to to
bomb to go to war so there was a sort of
lack of trust me stress so it was not
easy to overcome his mistress and to
arrive to to comment attitude of the
five and i think that's that's
unimportant that's an important element
the world has changed and that's the
reason why i'm not sure that for OSHA
and China their priority is to undermine
the strategic balance at the expense of
the of the u.s. so that's the really
certainly on the non-proliferation
regime we are first you know it has not
started with with Iran it has started
you know with all the activities of of
North Korea you know North Korea is the
ikea of polish eration you know really
you go there and you can buy whatever
you want you know really you can find
Korean you know Koreans everywhere you
know really I'm not going to give names
of countries that that's the case so
that's reason why and it was a u.s.
initiative that we have supported
actively we have had a resolution at the
Security Council with under the
presidency of of President Obama himself
in September resolution 1887 to combat
proliferation as I'm said it's very it's
much easier you can you can in a sense
you can buy elements of a bomb and
everything Keith you know really we
discovered it in 2003 when Libya
suddenly decided
so suddenly decided to become to become
knives and revealed the extension of
this program and we were all amazed
actually Libya had nearly about you know
as you know all the elements of a
nuclear military for a while maybe has
given up as given up this this program
but for us it has been also awaking
waking up call we have had so poor
information has become certainly and
again I go well beyond Iranian crisis
even if it's linked because there are
some sources of technology which are
coming you know you have had the a you
can pakistan you know network of
proliferation you have the activities of
of north korea which is exporting what
if ur technologies but also in size
everywhere basically to everybody you
can pay so it has led to a lot of
insistent on this on this on this issue
of proliferation all the regime of
control of exports at the title are much
much more much more effective but it has
of course it's also leading to other
questions for the future and one of the
big question is enrichment enrichment of
uranium you know because enrichment is a
really important rated proliferating
activity so there are a lot of different
proposals one of them russian in a sense
of giving countries you know because you
don't an arrangement for instance south
korea as a teen power plants south korea
doesn't enrich uranium because you can
buy uranium on the market enrich uranium
on the market it's cheap and actually
you know really so there there is no
need to in financial economic terms it
doesn't make sense to enrich uranium
before you have between 10 and 12
nuclear
grams so there is the question of
enrichment which is 4418 so how can we
control this activity which is not easy
because some countries are seeing that
as a way of restricting the excess
legitimate access to solve some
technology but there are Russian
proposals and other proposals to offer
enrich uranium facilities under
international control to other sort of
you know the International Agency for
atomic energy monitoring a sort of
international facility for enrichment so
which could give guarantee to countries
with which one to have nuclear energy
that they have access to to access to
fuel and reach and reach few there is
also a new insistence on nuclear
disarmament and especially after the
speech of President Obama on the under
on the world without nuclear weapons so
again there are a lot of questions
especially because in the world in the
globalized world everything technologies
people people and also materials
circulate of course much more much more
easy and again the technology of the
nuclear weapons which was maybe very
taken very difficult in the 40s or 50s
for most of the countries now it's
within reach of most of the countries so
that's that's the i guess the concerns
we have and and a lot a lot of things
are done and i'll done by everybody i I
think by a sort of consensus among the
international community with the
exception that countries are really
committed are really attached to the
idea that they they are right and we
shouldn't deny them
they're their heights to fit the
ambassador's schedule we're going to
have to make the next question the final
question congratulations oh thank you so
much Dennis I'm a grad student here at
Columbia and well I guess one of the
central arguments made by the the
Iranians and North Koreans is that if
India can detonate and test a nuclear
weapon and then after many years be
declared an official and nuclear power
nuclear state as well as Pakistan
afterwards and then if Britain France
the United States they can all test
nuclear weapons before and they're now
all officially recognized as nuclear
States within the international
community so why can't the Iranians and
North Koreans well because they've
signed the NPG the app sign to the NPT
the non-proliferation treaty is based on
on a deal the deal was in a sense to
close the club into the five-year five
nuclear powers but in exchange in the
sense in exchange the nuclear powers
were providing nuclear technology free
and access to nuclear technology for
nuclear civilian for use of for civilian
use of nuclear energy so that's the deal
of the NPT again you can consider this
deal is is not balanced nobody has ever
said that life is a fair place but that
that's the deal of the NPT and India has
not signed when pitching so India has
not violated any its obligations while
North Korea and Iran have signed
NP I know that at your at your age you
can consider that signing or not signing
your way to detail you're not really but
again that's that's really a sort of
legalistic nicety of really offer of a
diplomat you know really which is as you
know basically relevant to the real life
the diplomat actually the international
community the international life is
based on the sort of agreement Tweety's
we try to organize the international
life if you go out of the system if you
break your if you break your commitment
that that's that's that's a crisis you
enter into a crisis because you as I've
said you undermine all all the system in
a sense this entity system as you you
can emphasize is not balances it's a bit
weird it's a bit strange and which means
that it's very fragile and if somebody
starts by saying that the emperor has no
clothes it means that suddenly saying
why why we should accept it means that
the system is perhaps the system is his
pattern of collapsing the question if if
Iran violates its obligation if I'm not
saying that it does but if it were
violates its obligation there will be no
reason for other countries not to do it
so it's the end at the end of of the NPT
and again we are not rejoicing that
enjoying Pakistan of you know tested a
nuclear weapon but the fact is that not
signed they are not signed the nuclear
the nuclear doing pitching and secondly
which is very important and which is not
the case of North Korea especially for
India India as being has never been
associated with any proliferation
proliferating activities because it's a
it's a fact you have the nuclear
technology it's another fact to sell it
and India has not had any foraging
activity Israel has not have AG
proliferating activity with Pakistan you
have the problem of the aq can Network
so now apparently it is HS and under
control so thank you very much 22 up
being patient listen to me thank you
very much ambassador alcohol thank you
again ambassador haha I'm PF of the
school of internal public affairs thank
you as well to Professor bill yet and
thank you all for coming tonight